[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
which is where sam farmer the la times
he covers the nfl and
he moonlights covering the masters here
who joins us now sam thanks for joining
us by the way
i love the article that you had on the
sand at augusta
and i thought it would be great for this
audience to understand because when we
see it it looks like bowls of sugar
jim nance has referred to it that way i
just didn't know
to what lengths they went to bring this
sand
in so can you give us sort of the cliff
notes version of that
yeah dan thanks for having me on um so
the sand is from a place called spruce
pine
north carolina which is four hours north
of augusta
and really it's some of the most
valuable sand in the world or at least
it's a byproduct
of some of the most valuable sand in the
world spruce pine
geological mineral district has the
purest
courts in the world it has the fewest
impurities
and they use that courts to create
computer chips and so whereas quartz
sand would typically sell for about
fifty dollars a ton
the sand and spruce pine sells for about
twenty thousand dollars a ton
and uh so you can imagine the security
of the companies up there these
multinational corporations
have convened on this little town in the
blue ridge mountains this little
mountain town
and they're like wonka factories up
there
protecting protecting this sand well the
sand that is a waste product or sort of
not quite as pure um
has become the sand they use at augusta
and
it dates back to clifford roberts the
co-founder of the club
having a summer home up there loving
this white
sand that's just uh so sparkly
and and pure looking and um
wanting that for his club and it's
become so coveted
that spruce pine ships uh
recently shipped about 4 000 tons if you
can imagine that volume
4 000 tons of this to dubai
so imagine selling sand to the desert
well
this sand is so valuable and so coveted
and so sort of has so much sentimental
value
that uh and and you know a few years ago
a guy was arrested here at the masters
for trying to fill his beer cup
full of sand and so uh wait did he slip
inside the ropes and then just scoop it
up from us accidentally
he accidentally fell under the ropes and
then he accidentally
crawled over to a bunker how much did
they accidentally find him for that
they accidentally fined him twenty
thousand dollars and they haven't
rectified that yet so they
accidentally handcuffed him and brought
him to the ground and
and uh it was quite a quite a scene
so anyway this uh spruce pine sand is
is really cool and a lot of people
really confuse it for all different
types of
of minerals uh or you know they don't
know where it comes from
but do the players like it sam i think
they do
uh it sort of compacts very nicely
um it's very fine and uh
you know they feel they can hit off it
although tiger said
uh he feels like borrowing his catty
sunglasses every time he's in the bunker
it's so bright and so reflective
when uh i played augusta i did steal one
of my divots
i don't i don't know if they will come
after you if you steal
some grass i mean this is a long time
ago that i played but
i remember hitting a a div approach shot
on either 13 or 15 and i went man that
almost looks like a professional divot
i'm taking on put it in my bag got home
years later
i go oh my god i kept this up divot and
i had it in my bag there so
i don't know if if they police that
well you know i i would imagine they do
it was interesting
i believe it was sean powell of
sportswriter sean powell whose first two
rounds of golf
came uh at pebble b now imagine
your first two rounds of golf ever
pebble beach and augusta
his first two rounds of golf because he
played at the
u.s open the u.s open media day and then
he won the lottery here at augusta to
play on the monday after the masters
oh my god pretty much want to call it a
career after that just get pine valley
in and call it a career
sam farmer la times writer he covers the
nfl host of artificial friends
podcast here we were talking about
philip rivers michael irvin did an
interview last night
and he said i'll see you in five years
at the hall of fame is philip rivers
let me just start with is he headed to
the hall of fame
and is he a first ballot hall of famer
well in my book he's the first ballot
hall of fame guy
one of my favorite players uh ever
covering philip rivers
and uh certainly it's going to haunt him
that
that he had warning track power with the
chargers
uh they had some really good teams
especially 2006 going 14-2 and then
losing in the divisional round their
first game um
you know they never took it beyond
although he played really well in the
uh afc championship game against the
patriots
had him i think it was a one score game
into the fourth quarter and he was
playing on a torn acl
so you know like it's going to be a
tough
argument uh as a first ballot hall of
famer you've got to see who's going in
in that class along with him but uh as a
person
uh there's no better guy and it's it
surprises a lot of people because they
see him on the field and being so
uh uh you know throwing temper tantrums
on the field and everything but he is
the
the greatest guy i'll tell you a little
philip rivers story
he had to do a uh he committed to do a
men's retreat
and he's very uh devout in his
catholicism
a men's retreat in arizona when he was
in san diego
and uh there was a weather problem or
something something happened with the
flight
so he couldn't make it and most every
guy would call and apologize
and say sorry i couldn't make it this
guy hops in his pickup truck
makes the drive to arizona overnight
does the talk drives back so he does
about 14 hours
of driving just so he can uh make good
on that commitment so
he's you know i remember he he and his
wife took a vacation
a staycation to the hotel del coronado
one time and uh as they were checking in
this beautiful hotel in san diego
dwyane wade was checking in at the same
time and they sort of caught eyes and
dwyane wade gave him a head nod
like that philip talked about it for a
week
to his wife saying dwayne wade knew who
i was
and he's the guy who nodded to me he
knew who i was did you see that
and so it's sort of that tells you a lot
about fellow approvers he's so
unimpressed with himself
um that he will that will go down
as one of his greatest moments that
dwyane wade recognized him
in philip rivers of the pro bowl
quarterback so
again hall of fame guy and uh
probably a hall of fame player but i'd
sort of need to know who was around him
at that time
best team in california
right now is who
well you know the chargers are so
talented
uh they can't they can't win games so i
can't give it to them and the 49ers
are so broken down i would have to say
the rams
but you really have to
wonder if teams shut down the running
game the way that miami did and put it
on jared goff's shoulders
is he going to be able to come through
for you and i think
we'll know a lot coming out of this uh
out of this buy
how the rams are how they recover
they're playing seattle uh
sean mcvay's four and two against pete
carroll and those two losses came by
a total of seven points uh he's six and
oh against arizona
and so we're going to learn a lot about
this division but you know four other
five wins have come against nfc east
teams and
nfc east uh i think i wrote that nfc
east
winds have all the gravitas of packing
peanuts
so we just don't know how good how good
these teams are and we're going to find
out in the second half of the season and
i mentioned this i'll leave you with
this
i don't know if we're getting to the
jordan treatment of patrick mahomes
where
what else can we say what else can we
write now we're looking at hey is kyler
murray
an mvp candidate uh russell wilson
deserves to be in the conversation
i think when people look at mahomes
numbers
they go oh my god how did how did we
bypass that like we just skipped by that
because we're like oh it's mahomes he's
really good
um and i and you guys love to write a
good story here and that goes into when
people vote
sometimes you're voting because you're
voting for the best story
uh have we is there mahomes fatigue
already
it's funny uh mahomes is so good
that uh the little things that he used
to do that would have blown us away
switching hands or rolling out making
these incredible passes it's almost
worked against him because now we say oh
yeah that's my homes we've seen it
seen it you know and he's still doing
things that are
that are unbelievable you know i think
back to i talked to bruce arians about
patrick mahomes because cardinals really
wanted to draft him
uh when bruce was there and bruce said
you know he's one of the
four smartest guys on the board i've
ever had
and i said well who are the guys he said
well you know payton
and i'd certainly say andrew luck
putting him up on the board
and patrick mahome
and i said i said well i'm not going to
tell you the fourth guy he said because
every other guy i coach will think he's
the fourth guy
that's perfect but yeah mahomes is great
and then
and not to belabor this but i think it
really if you look back at the nfc
west and you mentioned two of the
quarterbacks there
i think the nfc west fits in two very
distinct buckets you've got
the play action good defense teams in
la with the rams in san francisco and
you've got the shortstop
type quarterback who each quarterback
played baseball
uh and who makes things happen in
seattle and arizona
and really defenses that leave something
to be desired so it'll be interesting to
see
in the second half of this season when
these teams start playing each other
which side prevails have fun down there
sam it's great to catch up with you
thanks for joining us
great thanks dan that's sam farmer la
times writer covering the nfl down at
augusta and host of artificial friends
podcast